I'm Hannah Elliot and I drive luxury
cars for Bloomberg's pursuits in this
episode of pursuits drive I'll take you
on a tour of Lombardy Italy near the
famous and picturesque Lake Garda
this is the gardening Riviera where
italians go on holiday to escape the
heat of nearby Milan and Venice
naturally you'll want an Italian car on
this trip so I recommend the Maserati
Levante Maserati turned 102 this year
and this is its first SUV pricing starts
at seventy-two thousand dollars start
your trip on the quaint promenade in
Tuscola no madera no locals claim this
waterside town was founded by the
ancient Romans head north hugging the
edge of the lake toward Lamoni su Garda
the 424 horsepower v6 is a Ferrari
engine that can jump to 62 miles per
hour in 5.2 seconds or easily conquer
hilly curves along the way Maserati is
such a iconic Italian brand this is the
middle of Italy it fits very well the
roads here are perfect for trying out a
new car especially a luxury SUV they are
very winding with lots of steep inclines
and declines and it really puts the
steering and the brakes and the
acceleration to the test
when you need a mid-morning break stop
for an espresso at Hotel la Terezin a
restaurant a or any of the small cafes
that dot the road along the way this is
Italy at its finest
when you finish your photos and espresso
head back toward the link you'll pass
through sun-drenched towns like provi
ona and sallow on the way back there's
even a button in here that can make the
engine two times as loud if you want it
which is pretty incredible and kind of
Rumble through these little towns almost
every town in the region has its own
open-air market you should stop and have
a light lunch
just like the locals do some biscotti
got the end I recommend the handmade
pastries very good thank you
now that you're re-energized head to
Frenchy quartet a region famous for its
organic wines the road wins through the
college farms open meadows and
pine-scented forests the Labonte's
8-speed automatic transmission and
all-wheel drive add to this room your
final destination should be the 11th
century vineyard of 1701 wine cellar
it's where Sylvia's defini and her
brother make just 3,000 bottles of wine
a year in the classic way by using hand
turning fermentation methods day by day
we turn the bottle high-end clockwise
yes when we make the second fermentation
of the wine the wine stained bottles for
years and years yes beautiful well I'll
drink to this
to some old chairs sipping a rare bubbly
rose' in a vineyard at Twilight this is
the perfect end to the perfect is how
you will drop perfect